num virus par danse c'est la question
qu'on se pose notamment après avoir
écouté ce matin cette sortie du
syndicaliste cgt et urgentistes
christophe que d'hommes will est un
exemple que je suis hors ce moment de
garde aux familles et hier soir des
annonces que le nord de l'italie était
une zone qui nécessitait de prendre des
précautions
nous avons une explosion d'athènes au
niveau du samu y compris des
renseignements parce que le numéro vert
qui a été mis en place d'un ministère
ferme à 19 heures
on est face à potentiellement une crise
sanitaire qui nécessitera la
mobilisation de moyens importants petits
moyens mais qui n'était pas sur les
moyens qu'on mettra un tour des moyens
qui seront pris ailleurs au détriment
d'autres patients et du fonctionnement
normal de notre gueule aux hôpitaux et
christophe prudhomme réagissait
notamment sur la mise à disposition de
70 hôpitaux supplémentaires qui venait
s'ajouter aux 30 autres pour gérer la
crise voici la réponse cet après midi du
premier ministre edouard philippe
partout en france où il ya un service de
sa bulle nous sommes prêts à accueillir
d'éventuels malade nous constatons qu'il
n'y a aucun malade hospitalisé en france
aujourd'hui atteints par ce virus
aucun aucun aucun à ce stade mais bien
évidemment nous sommes vigilants et nous
ferons toujours la transparence complète
c'est certain c'est une condition
indispensable de la confiance de nos
concitoyens alors rachel bina c'est ce
que vous êtes rassurés j'étais pas
inquiète et bien qu'en effet on sait
l'hôpital traverse une une crise elle
est pas récente elle date pas de de ce
mandat
elle est profonde on estime que 30 % des
postes de médecin à l'hôpital ne sont
pas pourvus c'est quasiment la même
chose pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants et c'est maintenant on a
une capacité d'accueil on a des
infrastructures on sait que la près de
s'ennuyer hôpitaux en tout cas
établissements se prépare à recevoir si
besoin des personnes qui seraient
touchées par par le virus genou
personnellement je ne vois pas de motif
d'être particulièrement inquiet béatrice
giblin tendance à dire on n'est plus
une épidémie de panique vraie épidémie
voilà dans la mesure où on sait que tous
les ans il ya des milliers de personnes
âgées qui vont mourir de la grippe qui a
un nombre de français qui ne se
vaccinent pas sur la grille puis on est
là ameuter les foules avec le
coronavirus je pense qu'on a des
structures de santé suffisamment solide
et est organisé pour faire face à ce qui
sera probablement pas une épidémie
massive
donc moi je suis un peu comme rachel
inquiète
alexis demain il ya un très beau match
de foot presque un derby olympique
lyonnais je viens tu oses de turin deux
maires de la banlieue lyonnaise s'oppose
à la venue des 3000 supporteurs italiens
ils ont raison je vais vous répondre
mais auparavant je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête un instant sur cette c2
nécessite de communes de principe que
restreint publics sont placés dans l'un
des sites et de devoirs articulé ou
concilier et c'est très compliqué et le
principe de rassurer en tout cas ne pas
inquiéter pas paniquer ça fait partie de
leur mission
quand on est en train public on ne
déclenche pas de panique c'est le
premier principe le deuxième principe
c'est de prendre toutes les mesures pour
éviter de mettre en péril la santé
publique et d'essayer de protéger
donc il faut rassurer et protéger car
parfois ça colle il ya des moments où
les deux principes peuvent entrer en
conflit dans la sphère de ceux de ce
stade c'est typiquement le cas si on dit
non les supporteurs de turan ne doivent
pas venir on faisait pas on protège les
gens du stade contre une éventuelle
contagion
mais du coup on inquiète parce qu'on dit
oh là là on fait donc ses sacs et des
visites moi je crois que il faut aussi
autant que faire se peut de ménager les
deux principes
je pense que malgré tout quand il faut
choisir il faut privilégier le second
c'est à dire la sécurité et la santé
publique peut-être pas parfois à tort
peut-être peut-être au risque d'en faire
trop mais je pense que que hauts risques
quand il ya de risques celui d'en faire
passer celui d'en faire trop le risque
d'en faire trop et finalement à la fin
moins grave donc en l'occurrence moi sur
cette affaire de vinci auprès d'eux
de principe de raison cette affaire de
matches de foot juste un truc que je
comprends pas on vit on le ministère
d'éducation donner une consigne pour
dire les enfants qui rentre d'italie on
doive rester chez eux
bon très bien on se noue le dire nous on
veut bien le croire on n'en sait rien
parce que ni bon et là dessus on dirait
qu il avait on disait les supporteurs
vont venir se promener et
écrit avec les autres dit un truc qui va
pas ou bien là il fallait pas le faire
ou bien l'autre il faut le faire mais il
ya que jusqu'à va donc moi je pense que
froid dans ce cas là il vaudrait mieux
dire non les supporters ils garderont le
match sur un grand écran j'ai eu à turin
c'est pas bien grave
pascal perrineau qu'est ce que justement
que réclame l'opinion à au gouvernement
à ce stade de crise sanitaire peut-être
que vous avez pas de données mais en
fonction de justement des autres a écrit
ce qu'on a pu voir comme le sera ce
comme le maire ce alors on veut on voit
une opinion dont l'inquiétude augmente
semaine après semaine mais il faut dire
que les titres de la presse les
interventions de nombreux élus de les
témoignages venant de l'ensemble de
l'europe les courbes voilà les courbes
de contamination le fait que ça se
rapproche de la france avec le foyer
italiens et les échanges nombreux entre
l'italie et la france ont bien en parler
font que l'opinion est inquiète
l'opinion donc elle attend on est en
france elle attend de la part de l'état
une réponse à la hauteur
elle se rend compte que le système
épidémiologique français est plutôt un
système de bon niveau
quand vous le comparer à d'autres
systèmes européens et vous le jugez sur
des crises précédentes comme celle du
strass comme celle de l'achat ena et
bien on avait été le système français
avait été à la hauteur
il reste une variable sur lequel il ya
une interrogation sait où on l hôpital
public
certes les hôpitaux publics sont là
prêts à répondre mais quelle est leur
capacité réelle en termes de personnel
quelle est la formation en amont sur ce
virus qui est tout même à virus complexe
parce que des individus ne peuvent avoir
aucun symptôme
et pourtant en être porteur donc quel
est le degré de formation parce que
quand vous regardez le cas italien
maintenant on commence à savoir d'après
le président du conseil ce qui s'est
passé en italie c'est le système
hospitalier italien qui n'a pas repéré
le patient numéro un et qui ensuite a
contaminé le personnel infirmier le
personnel médical et ensuite la
contamination est allé par un effet de
halo touché tout le nord tout le nord de
l'italie donc il faut en effet que
ça je suis incapable de répondre de
juger du niveau de préparation des
personnels et des services pour faire
face à un éventuel une éventuelle montée
en puissance il ya quelque chose qu'on
peut dire c'est que on répète sans arrêt
sur les médias ne vous rendez pas
l'hôpital appeler le 15 mais souvent le
seul le samu mais surtout c'est dans
l'hôpital que la contamination est la
plus forte donc si vous constatez que
vous vous êtes malade on vous
accompagnera mais dans un circuit deux
protections de façon à ce que vous ne
contamine n'est pas tout l'hôpital c'est
quelque chose qui est dit et redit il
semblerait quand même que et on le
disait avant savoir que ça s'était passé
comme ça en italie
donc je prends et je pense qu'il ya une
conscience réelle de la façon dont on
doit se comporter sur la sphère on a on
y déjà on aborder la question hier mais
sur la sphère du contrôle aux frontières
votre avis votre point de vue là encore
je pense pas qu'on puisse dire que ça
sert à rien je pense que non ça sert pas
à rien on peut dire que c'est pas
efficace mais grand port d'accord c'est
pas la même chose ça je porterai que je
vois depuis la section business
je pense que l'efficacité partielle
d'une mesure ne suffit le fait qu'elle
soit par ça ne suffit pas la condamner
sinon mettrai pas de limite de sérieuses
limites de vitesse ou motif qu'il ya des
gens qui les kills et qui l'excède qui
les franchissent et il ya des accidents
bon bien sûr rien ne permettre
d'empêcher une épidémie quand elle se
déclenche bon n'empêche qu'il ya des
choses dont on sait que ça l'a ralenti
il ya des précautions qui soit propre
là encore est ce qu'il vaut mieux un
embêtement temporaire et provisoire qui
ne fait rien traîner les gens aux
frontières pour leur prendre leur
température
bon oui c'est gaspiller c'est pas la
mort ou est ce qu'il vaut mieux prendre
le risque d'accélérer la diffusion d'une
épidémie c'est un rapport entre un coût
avantage
moi je pense que je vois pas ça me
paraît pas un immense drame que de faire
très attendre un peu des gens un poste
frontière on l'a tous fait autrefois
quand il y avait des vestiaires on
partait en vacances on n'aurait pas non
plus
mais un autre problème c'est que si vous
avez pris du doliprane non vous n'allez
pas pouvoir
je suis un des chefs et vous pouvez ne
parvient aussi à des gens qui passeront
à travers et voilà mais il n'a peut être
pas comme vous dit peut-être pas sûr que
ceux qui auront de la vielle seront
encore que ce soit clair il ne faut pas
le couple de l'otan tôt ça dépend ces
bénéfices coup là qu'est ce que vous
aurez comme une bénéfice ou qu'est ce
que vous avez comme qu avec cette
affaire création qui nous regardons fait
d'une pandémie mais l'épidémie politique
qui échappent au médecin
claudius nous dit les partis les médias
participent à la panique c'est votre
point de vue vous qui vient de mettre
travailler sur les sur le fait je ne
vois pas de panique
je trouve les gens extrêmement
rationnelle intelligente
voilà il y a une prévention qui est fait
il respecte il me semble respectée pour
la plupart les règles du jeu qu'on leur
demande
ensuite moi je vois aucun mouvement de
panique je vois pas de gens se confiner
chez eux
alors certes on me dira qu à des
ruptures de masques dans les pharmacies
de là à parler de panique non jeu réagir
à seulement contre comme emportements
tout c'est juste sous des menaces dont
vous dis tous les jours à la télé que le
moyen d'éviter la contagion
honnêtement ça me va je pense que les
médias informent réellement ensuite
alors s'y informer c'est à tirer comme
ça
la panique c'est autre chose on ne peut
pas à la fois demandé à ce qu'il y ait
une transparence et une fois qu'on donne
l'information considéré qu'on participe
à une panique qui en fait n'existe pas
ce témoignage de lucio qui nous
regardent qui dit que sa nièce revient
d'italie
du coup elle appelle le 15 et la réponse
qu'on les fait c'est que vous n'avez pas
de symptômes
donc ce qui se passe on ne va pas on en
fait un tabac dans les hôpitaux tout ça
c'est quand on parle d urgence il faut
aussi savoir faut pas se raconter
d'histoires c'est vrai que si on a une
épidémie de grande ampleur
on n'aura pas les moyens de mettre tous
les malades dans des chambres isolé
c'est normal mais c'est d'ailleurs pas
normal c'est un nombre de la déneigeuse
concorde kayes la neige entravaient
pourquoi on n'a pas d'aidé
des déneigeuses bien parce que ça arrive
que les 25 ans va pas équipés
l'administration les hôpitaux français
pour une épidémie c'est pas possible
donc c'est sûr que c'est une épidémie de
grande ampleur
les gens devront rester chez eux pour
beaucoup nos politiques sont toujours
avec un train de retard nous dynamo qui
n'ont rien sur youtube pour prendre de
réelles décisions tous les pays touchés
ont fermé leurs frontières nous des
avions venant d'asie d'europe continue
d'atterrir sur notre territoire il ya eu
vraiment s'inquiéter on voit poindre ce
sentiment dans l'opinion pas n'ont pas
encore pour l'instant n'ont pour
l'instant non mais vous savez ça ça peut
aller très vite
il suffit qu'il y ait un problème dans
un avion il faut faire et à ce moment là
en effet l'opinion virer pas
la france est elle à la hauteur dans la
gestion de la crise du corps un avis
c'est la question qu'on vous pose ce
soir sur twitter
réponse mi pense plutôt non 60 % donc de
ceux qui qui ont répondu on revient sur
cette question de toute façon demain on
fait une émission spéciale avec damien
mascret qui suit les kids genre et santé
du journaliste a bien signé un article
d'ailleurs dans le figaro qui dit
justement qu'elle est
quelle est la qualité et le niveau
de la france pour répondre à cette pour
apprendre à cette crise un article vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site du figaro
et puis on sera en direct avec sébastien
falletti qui lui est à pékin et en
demandant à houdan dans les papiers de
formidables alors la vie à pékin cela
n'en fait c'est un enfer et on lui
demandera justement où il en est et où
l'ennui de son confinement
l'autre question qu'on se pose c'est
c'est un autre
c'est une autre question qui revient en
boucle ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois c'est s'il faut suspendre
les débats à l'assemblée nationale sur
les retraites la question se pose parce
qu'elle a été posée par les députés
aient l'air notamment ce matin